the ghouls and freaks are on the prowl i
need sweets and treats to stop my
stomach grab i haven't thrown a
halloween party
in a minute i want this to be one for
the history bucks you understand
me you know my halloween queen will be
throwing this party with me i'll pick
the best bacon talent i'm on dozens and
dozens of treats i want a fortress upon
doctor
everything i do has to be big
welcome to our tasty manners
ready to make my halloween nightmares a
reality
halloween is one of my favorite holidays
are you up to it
from buzzfeed's tasty alvin zoe that is
insane this is the most crazy baking
kitchen i've ever been in it takes a lot
to meet my expectations boy do i know
[Music]
no more wasting time
ready to have some fun
oh that's spooky really creepy i'm just
shocked that so much of this is edible
everything is edible
oh get out of there alvin and they got
snoop's fingers what is going on man
that is our chocolate gato hold on
let's see what this ghetto chocolate
working with
you said you wanted a party
snoops you're slouching she's the only
one that can train this dog
can't wait for snooker martha's very
tasty halloween
[Music]
you